my thing i'm below the belt i think
boxing's a little bit of trouble because
now
nobody's nobody nobody besides you and
me
and some boxing heads are talking about
spence and bud or spence and
danny garcia everybody in the mom's
talking about logan paul and floyd
mayweather
damn and this is why we're talking about
tyson versus so is that
is that real yeah that's real yeah i'm
upset i talked to logan paul this
morning yeah
i'm upset with floyd though damn
he's the goat in my eyes and some can
disagree no that's fine
okay all right no 100 there's a definite
argument it's an argument you know he
chose his opponents you know he
cherry-picked whatever but
listen 50 tried 50th failed right yes so
if you're considered one of the goats
yes why would you even entertain now i
no it's exhibition money i know his
money i know and he does anything for
money but if you you can't argue this
if a if it was an exhibition put a head
gear on that's all i'm saying but this
is a real
boxing match and you consider one of the
goats you wouldn't see
jordan play i don't know lamelo ball
before you see what i'm saying that's
why i'm saying box in a little bit of
trouble because
logan paul's one and one wait no he's
only one
he's only one one he has one loss one
draw he didn't want to fight yet
oh was that a draw so he's owen one
technically yeah he's only been boxing
for two years
yes isn't he a bigger guy yeah way
bigger so why is he
that's why it's a little bit like but
even with that
like even though he's bigger it's floyd
mayweather dude yeah
it's a tie i don't know i don't know you
see how much paper
24.99 i know it's so cheap and and but
here's the thing if you get it early
it's 24.99 if you wait till the night of
the fight i think it's
69.99 a lot of people are going to buy
it it's money is floyd mayweather coming
back to the ring
if i'm floyd it's it's money in the bank
it's like hold up you want me to fight
the student get 100 mil
yeah i'll fight him it's 400 mil i'll
probably make 100 mil floyd really
doesn't do anything for less than 100
mil
yeah that's great yeah he's smart dude
but but if you're floyd
why wouldn't you do it well he's going
to do conor after that
but again he talked about it he goes
because they they asked him about the
connor fight i was watching this
interview and he goes
i took him out in the first round
because if i really wanted to apply the
pressure i would took him around the
first round he goes
but people paid money i want to give him
a show you guys also if i start them in
the first two rounds there's no rematch
yeah smart dude that's true meaning like
if you just went in and starts them
there's no rematch like
no one wants to see it got it now it's
like connor did pretty well
first six rounds let's be honest did
pretty well landed
and then kind of gassed out so it's like
oh if connor fixes that
yeah now this is me coming from mma side
it's like
all right if connor fixes that doesn't
gas out we got ourselves a fight but
that's what we're riding on and you're
gonna get my money for that well floyd
like he that's how he fights in spawn
he'll walk you down he's lit dog house
rounds
he is no minutes there's no time but
that's that's where everyone makes a
misconception about floyd oh he's such a
defensive fighter yes the
greatest defensive fighter of all time
go back to floyd it's early chris pretty
much
[ __ ] assassin's monster he could go
toe-to-toe with anybody
100 yeah but but now he's older and
wiser but it's an argument
from connor versus floyd when they first
started because
you can jump in it after this i'll make
this point when conor
was big in the ufc he was the best
striker in ufc correct hands it still is
okay still is
floyd best defensive fighter but it was
the illusion if conor hit him
man connor he's different floyd never
seen his style so was that and that's
the name
of isil that's why i got a job with
showtime yeah okay exactly now
in the paint i'm not narrative what what
does youtube jay paul
logan paul has to offer besides the
views i give well because logan paul is
so much
bigger than conor floyd i see floyd
sports i know
i know dude this is the narrative right
okay and it's kind of weird to go on it
because
jake paul did an interview chamber time
on below the belt
where he goes they go why how can you
beat connor he goes well i'm way bigger
because i'm way bigger i'm stronger and
i'm a bigger guy
it's like bubba bro
i told chan i said dude there's how many
bouncers in the world that all way
bigger than floyd or way bigger than
connor
and they would beat the [ __ ] [ __ ] out
of those guys
back to back easily in a bar fight so
why why do this fight and why not just
do the conference money the money the
connor and uh
because that kind of the rematch that
connor's never going anywhere he'll do
both he'll go
go fight logan paul i don't know how
many rounds it is six oh probably
probably six for him that's easy money
doug but now here's the but but here's
here's the
i'm just saying here's why they're going
to get my money okay what if logan paul
landed a big punt we said that about
connor connor landed a big punch but
he probably did that purposely you
should show me your videos
floyd was walking him down floyd doesn't
fight like that he's going to box
floyd can fight like that though yeah he
can't he showed everyone
that he's going to let logan paul like
get him gets the ropes and he'll be
chucking and driving
down listen i get what you're saying but
do you real in your honest
opinion do you really think he's going
to land on floyd mayweather something
silent
look at it so he got a draw here are you
lost
ksi i know oh my god
by the way he is he's kept talking he's
way taller than floyd
how tall is he like six two six two
years ago like two
hundred some pounds two two fifteen oh
my god but look at look no defense
you don't think floyd is gonna man
floyd's gonna walk him down
if floyd wants to he won't float him
floyd entertain it for
three four rounds you're right what
happened
um again what happens if in some thing
floyd's not respecting him let's just
say floyd's like this [ __ ] youtuber
have a thousand fights this is
money okay gets clocked but that's not
floyd mentality i'm just saying what
happens if he dead what if logan paul is
logan paul banking on that oh yeah
that's all he's banking on that's all he
really wants to beat his ass well
he thinks because he's they're smaller
he can go in there if he lands when it's
over
which is insane to think well i'll help
you get ready logan
help him get ready help him get ready i
mean you didn't you just
you're floyd's boy though right yeah
well i'm saying what would happen to
boxing if
if logan paul were to land and wobble
him i mean what would happen
to you then i then you get the
floodgates open of all these youtubers
mike perry's so funny my dm's mike
perry's like dog how long
how long are we going to pretend that
jake and logan paul can fight
and i damn to back him but yeah i said
dude i get it but then boy's making
money can't be mad at that
he goes i'm not mad i'm gonna teach my
he has a son coming he goes i'm going to
teach my son to be a youtube boxer how
much money they're making [ __ ] you
yeah i'm one of them well are the gates
already flooding ever since
uh yeah his brother jake paul knocked
out nate robinson
well like shannon sharp goes uh they go
are you excited for the logo
mayweather fighting he goes yes because
we're going to get him back he goes nate
robinson represented all of us as a
professional athlete yeah yeah yeah
right you're starting right now we're
going to get ours back
we got to even it up you're right we
need to get it back yeah
what if floyd does lose then it's more
it's better for boxing
no it's it's an exhibition it doesn't
count it's not going to go on this
record
and it doesn't though it does all of it
counts it does even though it's just
that he's got a point well you're the
only reason around the only one
hold on the only reason is the
exhibition is because you couldn't get
that sanctioned as a real
fight no but we know it's a fight well
yeah it's not like tyson uh
you can get you can get a section he had
two professional boxing matches
but against other guys that are o and o
against floyd who's
50 and oh yeah and has a thousand fights
no commissions in sanctions okay
they'd have to go like the dr or maybe
russia or something
japan
second fight florida guy second fight
two-time olympic gold medalist i know
but he was the commissioner knows that
though so they're going to grant that
access you know what i'm saying i'm just
saying like the only reason
my fight uh got sanctioned by
uh the nevada athletic commission when i
thought roy i only had four
fights doug he had over 30 and a former
world champion
i had four fights against just whoever
they should have never made that
no that would never get sanctioned but
they got sanctioned because it was an
ultimate fighter
and the ufc has the nevada state
athletic commission in their pocket
yeah because it was on multiple fighters
a tournament it got sanctioned but
let's say i signed with ufc at 4-0
and they tried giving me uh roy nelson
that probably wouldn't get sanctioned
i should have never been fighting that
man but you but you did and you won
i did not win that's when i lost the
ultimate fighter
oh cause oh because it was a mismatch
yeah
oh got you so the same thing with this
but did people watch it did people buy
into it
my favorite yeah the champion the most
watched of all time yeah so you know
same thing with this situation right i
get what you're saying
it's a mismatch in floyd it's an event
it's not even a boxing match it's called
the event because he
he said think uh tank davis with who we
all love is going to fight in the
co-main event but he wants to fight his
brother
so i'm like okay now this hey he wants
to fight jake's brother yes
we're going down a weird bro now you
understand why i'm coming
i don't know what dude i was speechless
on below the belt smart because i had to
break stuff down and
it's just like i don't know how to go
about it doesn't make any sense it's
just i don't know if it's good for
boxing like
i love logan logan's my boy i hope he
makes a
[ __ ] 100 million dollars but just
like
i i don't know i don't know where you go
yeah i don't know where the sport goes
they wouldn't do this in ufc at all
never thank you so i'm saying so boxing
because you know what we're talking
about ufc
tony ferguson versus uh charlie oh
charles oliveira which is an insane
fight
insane fight number six verse number
three like that's a fight
yeah but no yeah why is boxing doing
this well but but
you you discredit earl spence and danny
garcia very too skillful by boxing
uh two of the best and and their views i
think we'll get the numbers uh
can't be great what do you mean i bet
you it's less than four hundred thousand
it was pay-per-view right yeah okay i
think the numbers didn't come out yet
though
no it's just saying i think it's too
soon but but but look at the tyson and
roy jones that was like over a million
pay-per-view box 1.6
yes but now is that roy and tyson or is
that jake paul
who's the the most famous guy in the
card and
starched homeboy yeah that made that
made you know what i'm saying it's like
but but i'm saying now it's a mockery
now you have now you got mayweather
and lo oh oh click on how much spence
and danny garcia made
right there i think it made over like i
said purse buyouts yeah
i know i know earl got over a million
right
yeah over one million plus revenue share
of pay-per-view
yeah so you know he's making [ __ ] man
two three million uh a fight off that
fight yeah but i'm
i'm saying it and that's low for earl
but i'm saying this now
i watched sports and i watched
undisputed i watched all that this
morning hey
no one no one mentioned like a very
few sisters yeah it was a tiny segment
and then
do you know what majority of the segment
was floyd versus what i'm saying yeah
it's like no one cares about like that
but imagine you growing up you know who
else is fighting who anthony joshua uh
oh and po
apollo the heavy heavyweight it's a
great card that's a great noise it's
next saturday oh this saturday this
saturday
and you know it's crazy yeah yeah joshua
us
got kovale uh what's his name uh
klitschko ready for the guy he's
fighting
and my the guy who used to uh train me
my old boxing coach is training the
heavyweight public who loves
no [ __ ] punk now he's not who is he
looking
though he's over he's also like a
smaller heavyweight yeah but
he's a huge dog
yeah but this guy's old as hell cool
he's cool yeah that's him right here oh
this would be a good fight
yes that old face no the the according
to vegas odds like
but he just shows that i want to watch
it minus 4 000.
yeah but this is a huge if you guys
don't want to snuggle up and watch it
this weekend
i'm gonna watch it yeah i'm gonna watch
it as well shout out to my coach
trying to hang out i'm saying you guys
are my favorite fighters you think so
i love joshua i don't know i like john
tyson fury no tyson
is my favorite boxer oh okay okay i'm
about to say tyson
you know all of them yeah easy
but i'm saying imagine you growing up
all your life boxing and you like a earl
spitz and you get overshadowed because
this one his biggest
like he literally came back from a year
and a half layoff because that
crazy actually bro that accident was you
saw the car did you see it it was
brutal right and he comes back and fight
the top
three welterweights in the world no too
enough yeah she's a monster a monster
and
and dismantled him and it's a little bit
a little bit i probably know bro it was
even a
clicker on espn it wasn't remember it's
up there it's another organization
so it was on i forget what it was on my
i forget who put it on but but is that
so is that boxing's fault
oh yeah boxing's a nightmare because
it's basically all
different leagues yeah like the almost
they're they're called promoters like
one with bob aaron yeah the others
hopkins
oh heyman alhamdu abc yeah al hayman uh
aaron are the two big dogs
but it's basically like bellator and ufc
they don't really cross pollinate no
that's a real problem but it's bob aaron
fought like bob
it's all their fault like you can make
the deal if you wanted it's everybody's
fault
yeah golden boy bob aaron yeah it's just
it's not good and so ufc just keeps it
just
well well keeps it i mean keeps it 100
they
they like you want it like this matchup
of ferguson
and charles oliveira that's fight we all
want to see they don't do these build up
fights where it's like
you're going to fight this person before
you fight deontay walden
if you're ranked five it's again if you
if you're in the top 15 you're not
fighting the 27th guy
you're only fighting ahead of you 15
fighting 14 that's awesome 13's fighting
10 10's fighting five five's fighting
four
and three's fighting two and then
whoever wins that's gonna fight one
like there's a reason to they're mad why
don't they do that in boxing because
boxing has way too many belts
now way too many now it's hard to keep
they don't need that many huh
it's just it's for the public it's just
confusing
oh you know ryan garcia is a silver
champion you know what that is
no exactly so i think that
yeah unboxing just like like get rid of
all these paper
like in the same weight class tank davis
is the champion
yeah dan van heenly is a devin hainley
is a champion
and ryan garcia is a champion why
doesn't ryan fight tank davis well we'll
be they're trying can we get that can i
can i request that a bad fight for
ryan right honestly but he's just not
ready yet but that's the other thing is
like
he's promoters young dude he has a way
to go so in the ufc it's like
ryan would probably be ranked in the
he'd be like 15th or 14th okay they're
not going to match him up with the
number one guy in the world
they're not going to do that to him no
they'd give him 14
and then you give them 10 then you give
them five i love that but here's
when we then we go on the right we going
so he'll never fight tank
well yeah but if you listen ufc i love
that's a great analogy right
the guy let's say ryan davis is 15 in
usc tank davis is number one
number 15 has the belt as well do you
understand what i'm saying
so he feel like he's a champion so he's
oh so
not really he's not really a champion so
then you go you go to the table table
like yo i want 60 40. you're like bro
you knocked the champion he's not i've
seen him knock some [ __ ] out
not tank davis no but do you do can we
bring it all right
hey pull up when ryan knocked out um no
no no you're not fighting anybody you're
not hearing me he's not fighting anybody
no no you're not hearing me
tank davis isn't he just knocked out
granted
i i guess uh santa cruz he moved up but
that santa cruz is like still top
san cruz amazing amazing knock them out
put them to sleep yeah
ryan davis if he gets into he don't want
to see garcia i get it i love heart
i'm sorry ryan garcia yeah i love his
heart i love it
he's a future but it's just like so
those dudes he's knocking out aren't
really good tomato keys they're they're
but that's boxing like in by like in
boxing that's the difference between
boxing ufc and mixed martial arts is
like
in boxing guys go 50 like four it's
50 and oh yeah and that's why you feel
the way you feel about tyson
because you didn't feel like he didn't
find any fight anybody yep
but he was scared he did fight some
people but every time he matched up he
he lost he lost like louis you know
evander holyfield
he's trying to invent the holyfield say
he wants to get some again damn
he's not over the everything vandy
holyfield was uh sparring with that
uh big [ __ ] uh the one that
knocked out joshua
you saw my andy uh oh really please yes
there's a video there's a video of them
sparring yeah type it in i ain't joking
i think wilder's fighting i'm watching
rui's next
think so i don't need to get back on
track
no man wilder is in a dif he's in a like
a weird space
spars with uh ruiz
andy andy yeah andy i guess andy
are you yeah
this is over a year ago though right it
said nine months ago
look at that holy [ __ ] no this is a good
this is 2011
2011 oh well still hey
sorry i thought it was recent my fault
but it's still amazing
that's nine years ago though i'm sorry
my bad that's nine
holy face years ago yeah yeah but is it
how old is he
uh 79
i love my youtube i'm trying to keep up
with this boxing world hey you thought
about that too when he said 79 he was
like
i don't think there's any current video
of holyfield no
no but but i bet if he got back in there
he's a man look how crazy boxing is now
we got legends coming back he's 58 years
old he's 58
like boxing looks great boxing is in
these clouts so bad like you know what i
mean
it's the only way boxing's making any
mainstream news unless floyd comes back
look at canelo canelo is a beast and
he's having we don't know who he's going
to side with
he's fighting people yes he he he
actually fights
column smith yeah colin smith how many
times do you fight triple g
uh three twice no they want to do three
but canelo is kind of over it
yeah triple g is older now he's like i'm
good dude yeah i'm trying to fight these
other dudes
oh got it i want to see earl versus uh
canelo
look at him that's what was this
uh last week i guess november yeah let's
go he looks great for 58.
now he's always in shape that's one
thing about holy look at him he's about
to get the jump ropes in
oh dude when he fought mike tyson he'd
finished fifth in mr olympia he was
jack what is that video right look at
the one with the dog
or the dog that's that's you're the one
you see the dog
he looks great you took a picture with
the dog this weekend brittany
yeah did that lady was really into her
dog
[Laughter]
he was running what is this one
yeah i remember that i was like oh
come on man ooh
that happened
a lot of people think because tyson was
getting beat up he found a way out
which is true tyson's camp says uh he
kept having
vander kept head button that's what he
does right yeah
which is true damn look at evander
holyfield's body bro
he is huge let me ask you a question and
all y'all can
chime in he's beating the [ __ ] up he's
been if
evander holyfield would have just like
talked cash money [ __ ] like
floyd mayweather and tyson but he was
always on mute but
he's like i'm gonna let my fighting do
the talking i know but that's why he
wasn't a bigger
and that's why the narratives that
tyson's the best ever and but it's like
damn holy field beat them twice yes yes
crazy yes
wait so was the rematch the earbuds that
was the rematch right there the first
one that was a rematch
so we had his ear back on am i wrong
i don't understand these questions you
asked i don't i won't i wonder about the
ears
he had a chunk out of his there he had a
chunk out of his hair did you know
someone selled it online
who caught it you know what dude every
funny tyson just threw it the [ __ ] out
in the crowd
type of havana was pissed oh i was
jumping around
yeah still missing oh he can get surgery
for that though
wow how about that when i get off stage
at the lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son